s'il vous plaît déconnecter tes catald 4
dans une carrière de sable loin des
regards on exécute les derniers
préparatifs pour tester ce petit moteur
on a environ une centaine de capteurs
branche un peu partout sur le moteur qui
nous permet d'avoir des données de
pression température l'entreprise
réaction dynamique
veut dire la première fusée
qui la commence avec des tests de moteur
et de carburants
la fusée qui sera développée par
réaction dynamique vise à mettre en
orbite des microsatellites il y a
beaucoup de compagnies de satellites qui
font des choses extraordinaires il y a
des compagnies qui sont capables de
détecter du méthane bientôt du dioxyde
de carbone à partir de l'espace tu as
des compagnies qui sont capables de
fournir d'une alternative nous notre
travail c'est de prendre ces satellites
là puis il a lancé sur la bonne orbite
le marché des petits satellites se
développe rapidement
18500 d'entre eux pourraient se
retrouver au dessus de nos têtes
réactions dynamique veut se tailler une
place dans ce secteur lucratif déjà
occupé entre autres par l'entreprise de
Elon Musk space ex ou encore par Rocket
Lab en Nouvelle-Zélande c'est
extrêmement difficile de rentrer sur le
marché des lancements d'être profitables
sur l'opération le développement la
fabrication d'un lanceur tout simplement
parce que ça coûte beaucoup et justement
au Royaume-Uni the Norbit a récemment
déclaré faillite elle tentait de lancer
des fusées accrochées à un Boeing 7,47
la situation est complexe pour les
petits lanceurs mais néanmoins il
servent à un marché de niche des
certains clients sont prêts à payer un
premium pour arriver quand il veulent où
ils veulent en orbite c'était justement
l'objectif de Bachar el design son
entreprise a d'ailleurs reçu près d'un
million 500 mille dollars de l'Agence
spatiale canadienne va offrir c'est
d'offrir la convenance du taxi
avec un prix qui est similaire à ce que
tu paierais pour une fusée sur SpaceX le
coût approximatif 8000 à 25000 dollars
canadiens par kilo un des facteurs
majeurs qui détermine le coût d'une
fusée c'est ta propulsion quasiment 70%
c'est la propulsion ce qui nous
distingue c'est qu'on utilise une
propulsion un peu nouvelle technologie
de propulsion hybride ou le carburant
est sous forme solide et l'Occident est
sous forme liquide si les tests de
moteur s'avère concluant d'ici un an un
prototype de fusée comme celui-ci
devrait être lancé après quoi le rêve de
Bachar elsaï pourrait bien devenir
réalité ici marisabelle Rochon
Radio-Canada Saint-Jean